Hey, what's up guys! I'm back today
with this mystery box,
and a little bit of a disturbing
experiment today.
This experiment comes from the comment request from Valentin Gjorgjiovski who asks,
"I've heard a pig heart is really similar to humans so I think it would be cool if you cast one in chocolate! It could be a video close to valentines day! Instead of regular chocolates, you do an actual heart...."
That is very disturbing Valentin, but I'm slightly intregued,
so today we're doing this video for you.
So I jumped on the internet and found a company that actually does sell pig hearts and they shipped me this box here
that's 5 pounds and contains two of them, I've
been keeping them in the fridge and you
and I are seeing this for the first time
together.
Oh my goodness... Holy heck, I had no idea
they were gonna be that big! I was
thinking like a human heart...? I don't know.
How big that is like the size of your
hand? But that is that's a good fistful.
I mean that's giant. Now when i ordered
these things it said that they were preserved
hearts so I imagine this is formaldehyde. We
got down here that's nasty stuff so
we're gonna rinse these off, clean them
up as much as we can before we cast in the
silicon. Happy valentines day my heart
i'm not exactly sure how that compares
to a human heart I mean our hearts
really this big I have no idea i can't
really see how that would fit inside but
this is fascinating
I've never actually held a heart in my
hand before was always been intriguing
to me about hearts as they don't
actually look like the heart-shaped
Valentine's suppose if you got really
creative and use your imagination you
could be a heart shape right here but
parts that we use for Valentine's Day
look nothing like this if everything
goes to plan today I think we're going
to have the world's first real chocolate
hard-heart dab he might be wondering
what this feels like
and as I press into it's actually
amazingly firm is quite hard part of
that is probably because it's been
sitting in the fridge for a couple weeks
that's probably because pressure but
yeah it's very very firm it's almost
like it's almost like pushing into
somebody's flex muscles very very very
thick a little bit rubbery that's a
little disturbing kind of backed off
yes the side looks a little bit nicer
that smells like biology class
yeah now both of these hearts with a
little bit different but I'm kind of
favoring this one here is a little more
elongated has more of the heart shape
and i think it just looks a little bit
better
if a guy's our heart is secured in the
box i use 13 screw from the backside to
hold hard place and that's what went
before the silicon the heart won't float
up that should hold it securely down the
bottom and just for good measure let's
but one strand of duct tape along the
gaps and cracks of this box to the
silicone doesn't leak out caution heart
surgery in progress
you did so all we have to do now is mix
up some silicone pick in the vacuum
chamber and then pour it into a
container for this confirm up and give
us our heart shape mold and this time
we're going to use a blue catalyst to
give us a blue silicone mold that we
haven't tried doing that before
here we go guys are silicon is
completely the gas we have to do now is
let the air back in and we can transfer
to our more
that's wild now it's not super critical
that we pour this perfectly but i am
going to do it using the proper
techniques we learned in previous videos
and get for it in a little drizzle this
corner here so our first batch is poured
and it's looking nice and bubble three
but only covers the heart about
one-third of the way we're going to make
two more batches the exact same way so
we can top this thing up and cover it
completely
oh wow there's like Silicon coming
through whatever that thing is ok we
just finished our last batch of silicon
and we only have maybe a quarter inch
left we need to go up on the small so i
think we're going to get this thing done
you can see it's a little bit different
color and that's because he is clearly
more catalysts in this one I didn't
measure it out properly like I should
have done but whatever i think it's
going to get the job done so you should
be good
alright so update guys we got this thing
filled almost to the top of silicon I
thought we might have used too much but
it turned out to be perfect so we
currently have a giant pig heart sitting
in this mixture of silicon is going to
need a few hours to set up so we're
going to cut here in the next video I
will cut this open filled up with
chocolate and we're going to do a
chocolate heart reveal what's it going
to look like what's going to smell like
the smell of the heart of diffuse into
the chocolate itself isn't even going to
be edible
I have no idea but we're gonna find out
in the next video so until then big
thanks to andrew Jensen for suggesting
this experiment it's a little bit creepy
from doing it for you and for the rest
of you thanks for joining me for this
video and i'll be looking for the next
one
talk to you then you always do we get
the heart back out it's freezing in
liquid nitrogen